[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 culture tout de suite le sommaire de
ce mercredi 11 janvier
cette semaine le prix smile en cours
passe à l'heure du hip hop
une exposition est consacrée à cet art
urbain une exposition interactive à
laquelle de danseurs amateurs
participent
nous allons assister à une répétition
l'artiste peintre samuel gélas s'inspire
de la violence de sa guadeloupe natale
dans ses oeuvres des toiles aux couleurs
vives dans un style pop art et en ce
mois de janvier de nombreux ouvrages
sortent dans les librairies une petite
sélection non des non exhaustive de
livres a dévoré cette semaine je disais
le hip hop un reste investi le prisme à
elancourt à partir du jeudi 12 janvier
une exposition est consacrée à cet art
urbain
un rendez vous un peu particulier parce
que l'exposition est interactive et se
base sur des vidéos des amateurs saint
quentinois sont mis à contribution au
travers d'une installation il était en
pleine préparation samedi dernier
nicolas landry les erreurs les a
rencontrés regard des besoins des fables
ou et danseurs professionnels
ce samedi ils étaient là pour encadrer
une dizaine de personnes qui
performeront au prisme
je vais préparer les amateurs qui sont
avec moi
à une installation qui s'appelle
freestyle ou le but du jeu c'est de
mettre en relation des gens qui sont
dans un espace avec d'autres personnes
qui sont dans un autre espace via une
connexion internet et un ipad
du coup le but c'est de faire danser les
gens dans un endroit à l'autre
pas de création particulière pour cette
performance
freestyle se base sur l'improvisation et
sur l'interactivité pas de
professionnels non plus les participants
de cet atelier sont tous amateurs
ça me faisait une occasion de partager
avec le public danse et de préparer
quelque chose là ces professionnels avec
un danseur d'une compagnie
professionnelle et de partage avec le
public plutôt que de danser dans ma
chambre depuis tout petit je danse en
freestyle autodidacte plutôt hip hop new
style dont le début mois déjà de
rencontrer des gens et aussi le fait bar
de pouvoir se lâcher on connaît pas les
gens devant qu'ils ont dans ce sens
voilà il ya et puis le fait aussi de
pouvoir apprendre des nouveaux pas parce
que moi je travaillais beaucoup sur la
house si on fait est là bas ont
travaillé un peu de break d'europe boc
d'être en contact avec le public de leur
transmettre des mouvements de leur
apprendre des choses ou que même eux ils
peuvent nous apprendre c'est aussi
bah s'amuser avoir une bonne ambiance
quatre heures de travail qui s'intègre
dans l'exposition danse des guerriers de
la ville un parcours imaginé par la
compagnie par terre à découvrir le 14
janvier prochain
jusqu'au 3 février le conservatoire des
arts de montigny le bretonneux accueille
un jeune peintre diplômé de l'école
nationale supérieure des rats des arts
de paris cergy samuel gélas s'inspire de
son île natale la guadeloupe et on
dénonce une certaine violence
un sujet un sujet réalisé avec ma tin de
2010 des visages dur effrayant un
enchaînement de personnages des
métaphores animales à travers des
oeuvres réalisées entre 2014 et 2016
samuel gélase dénonce la violence je
rentrais en guadeloupe en 2014
en 2014 la guadeloupe été le département
le plus violent français donc j'ai été
frappé par cette violence que je voyais
que je côtoyais un petit peu de près et
à partir de cela j'ai entre amis en tout
cas ça m'a inspiré pour une bonne série
d'oeuvres des gants des artistes qui
s'appelle les chiens marie leyen en fait
donc ils se donnent des noms d'animaux
et je me suis inspiré de cela je me suis
aussi inspirée du conte créole antillais
une inspiration qu'il retranscrit dans
de grandes toiles fait à l'acrylique et
à la pierre noire une certaine critique
du monde à travers du pop art que l'on
retrouve dans la deuxième partie de
l'exposition qui elle s'inspire de negri
side à néologisme inventé par un artiste
guadeloupéen il fait tout un travail en
fait sur la dimension génocidaire de la
traite négrière et toujours en utilisant
des métaphores qui font référence au
monde animal à ce genre de choses qui
peuvent exprimer une certaine humanité
un thème traité par des couleurs chaudes
et des traits fins attirant l'oeil décor
distendu pour exprimer une libération
une émancipation
on continue avec une autre exposition de
poèmes cette fois jusqu'au 29 janvier le
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines accueille tout est sorti de la
terre une exposition d'une vingtaine de
textes inuits issus des poèmes eskimos
de paul emile victor ou encore de
l'anthologie des champs de la toundra de
pierre léon ses poèmes ont été
rassemblés par les itinéraires poétique
de l'agglomération écoutez jacques
fournet le directeur de ces itinéraires
même si cette poésie nous parle pourra
nous semblait dans tout au moins dans sa
première partie un peu simpliste dans la
forme on n'est pas dans des des images
lyriques comme on a pu connaître en
europe
non mais on comprend que cette écriture
là comme celle qu'on aurait pu trouver
dans d'autres pays du monde nous touche
parce qu'elle concerne elle et elle elle
nous parle elle parle de notre quotidien
nous aussi cette exposition est proposée
dans le cadre d'un spectacle in une
création collective de l'unijambiste un
voyage à travers le grand nord ronin
envie que la terre a désigné le
spectacle est à découvrir du 25 au 28
janvier au regard d'un extrait
[Musique]
et si pour 2017 vous plongiez temps des
livres avec plus de 75000 titre édité en
moyenne chaque année difficile parfois
de s'y retrouver
une librairie saint-quentinoise nous
présent des ouvrages à ne pas manquer
pour cette rentrée de janvier une liste
non exhaustive bien sûr les images sont
signés camille landais réalise des
champs article 353 du code pénal de
tanguy viel un titre peu accrocheur pour
un ouvrage coup de coeur de cette
librairie unis monteyne on suit les
confidences faites à un juge d'un
ouvrier brestois coupable de meurtre
c'est vraiment un livre non très
émouvant sur la relation que peut avoir
un père avec son fils là qu'il essaye
d'amener malgré lui enfin qui va emmener
malgré lui dans sa chute et la relation
qu'il ya aussi avec la société quelle
quelle vision à la société sur les
ouvriers brestois de l'époque des années
90 alors c'est plus dédié vraiment à
tout type de lecteur fin vraiment c
c'est très simple en fait c'est plus de
l'oralité en fait le dialogue en fait
entre le juge et le s est ouvrier là est
transcrit sans mise en forme
c'est vraiment un discours en discours
en brut pour les amateurs de polars
seuls les bêtes de colin niel un roman
choral loin de l' enquête policière
habituels autour d'un meurtre il ya cinq
racing en fait qu'ils vont vivre la
scène de l'assassinât de cette femme qui
est qui est retrouvée morte dans une
voiture dans un sentier de randonnée
pardon est en fait les cinq personnages
vont décrire le contexte ce qu'ils ont
vécu durant le moment et ce qui s'est
passé après
au rayon bande dessinée flotte un parfum
de nostalgie un certain journaliste
belge à la houppette blonde voit ses
premières aventures mise en couleur donc
là les traits sont épurées français le
toutou premier c'est les prémices de
tintin alors là et rejet n'avait que 22
ans
donc c'était vraiment son tout début et
il s'imaginait pas que ce son petit
reporter la les durées
quelques siècles derrière lui c'est une
belle découverte je pense que pour
rentrer dans un temps aussi on peut
commencer par le début ça peut être bien
depuis 1939 première date de parution de
tintin chez les soviets près de 240
millions d'albums des 24 aventures du
journaliste se sont vendus à travers le
monde
[Musique]
le coup de coeur cinéma de la semaine
c'est celui de bertrand pigné des yeux
d'elsa saint cyr l'école on l'écoutait
alors le coup de coeur du cinéma les
yeux d'elsa cette semaine c'est un film
sorti en 1977 probablement le plus grand
film de 1977 et non c'est pas star wars
c'est sorcerer de william friedkin un
film qui est complètement passé inaperçu
à cause justement de star wars et qu'on
vous propose de re découvrir au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa pour une projection
unique le vendredi 20 janvier à 20h30
projection qu on accompagnera de
discussion sur le film vous expliquera
comment il est fabriqué et comment et
pourquoi il a été fabriqué c'est un film
plein d'anecdotes qui devait rassembler
steve mcqueen mastroianni ventura et qui
finalement a rassemblé riders bruno
cremer est bien d'autres c'est un film
qui a eu une aventure absolument
formidable c'est un remake du salaire de
la peur de clouzot c'est une
réinterprétation dans la jungle
tropicale du mexique du
du fameux film le salaire de la peur de
georges clouzot donc on sera au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa le vendredi 20 janvier à
20h30 avec sylvain ibères mon camarade
professeur au lycée mansart de saint cyr
pour vous parler de ce film
j'espère que vous serez nombreux à venir
profiter de cette projection il
[Musique]
et comme chaque semaine quelques rendez
vous à noter dans vos agendas le premier
elles sont quatre deux violonistes une
violoncelliste et une altiste le quatuor
ardeo joueront le jeudi 12 janvier au
théâtre saint quentin des oeuvres de
haydn de chrome ou de schumann regardez
cet extrait enregistré lors d'une leur
répétition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aux clayes-sous-bois ce sera un concert
de jazz et l'arabe essonne et le trio
acquaviva revisite des standards de jazz
principalement ceux de la grande ella
fitzgerald
la rage et la fin nous serions tous
heureux est une création autour des
sentiments de l'enfermement et de
bonheur l'oeuvre de l'accompagner le
dahu se joue ce vendredi au théâtre
eurydice regardez cet extrait
[Musique]
on
vraiment ça fait combien de temps que
des sorties à l'auditorium de la
batterie vous pourrez découvrir les
regards croisés d'un compositeur et
d'impôts être penché sur le berceau du
divine enfants le concert s'inscrit dans
le cycle sacrée musique il était écouté
le dimanche 15 janvier pour les amateurs
de cirque et de balais direction la
merise attrape les gandini juggling y
présentent leur spectacle qui mêle du
jonglage et de la danse avec une
précision parfois mathématiques regardez
et
le cetud culture est maintenant terminée
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]